[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's up
Sarah hey what's
up um well I've got a kind of
interesting question um interest rates
are really bad right now I know that I
understand that um we have a situation
with our neighbors that has just become
increasingly toxic and um we've had to
like call the police on them and a lot
of a lot of bad things gone down I won't
go into all the details but um I still
would like to move because I feel like
um this is a bad situation for me and my
family and I feel like we can afford to
move but my husband is just it's killing
him to try to sell this house with the
interest rates what would you say
because the in what's your interest rate
right
now it's like 7% some something around
there yeah okay and the houses are
expensive in this area yeah so the house
you're living in now how long have you
been living there
we've been living here for eight years
and you've got 7% it's not
less um right now we're at like a 2.5 a
15 year a great rate he doesn't want to
sell yeah that's what I wanted to verify
when you said it was seven I was like
wait what um yeah gotta got look that's
the that's the quandry that's the
conundrum that so many Americans are
facing it's like okay am I just going to
live in this house forever cuz I didn't
intend to but at the same time I don't
want to take you know a 5% hit in hit on
my interest rate
so I the way I like to frame this in my
brain is you don't let the market
interest rates all these other uh
factors that we can't control determine
when it's time to buy a house what
determines truly when it's time for you
to buy a house when it's time for you to
move is a if you can't afford to and B
if you want to and they have to go
together if you can afford to that's
thing one that's got to be in place and
then you've got like do I do we want to
move as is this the best for us and for
the picture that we have of our family
so those are the things that go together
in this case it sounds like they're both
aligning but it sounds like your husband
is a little bit more like looking at the
numbers he's more of the math guy
right he's a little bit of a scrooge
yeah but um okay but hold
on what give me some insight into what's
going on because if I had a bad neighbor
situation where I had to call the police
to keep my family safe yeah and my wife
came to me in tears and said I've got to
get out of here I don't care what the
we're we're renting I know right I'm out
so either the neighbors aren't that bad
are they loud are they sitting in like a
one of those little kitty pools that
they got at Walmart and they're drinking
too much are they selling like drugs and
violent yeah oh well there's a combo
there's a loud music but also um just
the wife has become increasingly hostile
to my husband screaming and swearing at
him and just for and like whenever she
can and then the their kids have been
just historically really unkind to my
kids but then now they've just taken to
like always flipping them off and then
it got really bad um rocks were thrown
at our house and there was messages
written on our driveway saying move out
and all this kind of stuff and so we
called the cops the cops told us to put
up cameras and after we did um the wife
of this in this other house um published
online that um we're perverts trying to
watch them in their pool and um I really
feel like I'm on like Mory right now
like this is this is good
radio you are not the
father and then we told him to get off
my lawn I'm just kidding this is yeah D
this is like this is like taking us back
to to Middle School like elementary
school so right I I
would I don't know why isn't your
husband concerned about
this he is he is um we're we're we had
the cops come over the cops saw our
footage of our cameras and saw we're not
looking at them at all we're just
looking at our own property because um
they're the ones who are throwing the
Rocks they've done it many times and we
just need camera proof now and anyways
so
um he is upset we had the cops tell them
not to do not to trespass but at the
same time like they're still flipping us
off they you know it's just still an
ugly situation well so so so okay so
it's twofold here number one you have a
picture of your house of this life you
want to have and it's where all the
adults are rational and all the kids get
along and that's not your world right
right right so you have to make peace
with either a I'm going to teach my kids
there's just some those kids are growing
up in a tough situation and so we are
going to not give them space and our
souls were going to head out and you're
not going to play with them they're rude
and if they flip you off that's that's
rude and we're going to move on mhm or
you can walk away and the it's it's that
old saying not by your hand but in your
lap you didn't cause this and yet here
it is and when you take responsibility
for your own life it always always comes
with consequences always I refuse to be
abused anymore okay well now you're a
single mom and you're going to have to
figure it out yeah I refuse to be in
debt anymore okay tough guy now you got
to work three jobs for the next two
years it always comes with something so
if you say I am sick of my kids getting
flipped off which you should be by the
way I'm sick of my husband next thing
she's going to accuse my husband of
something and it's going to be a mess
totally get it and you're going to have
to sacrificed 4% on an interest rate
somewhere or rent for a year well let's
talk about these dollars and cents
because I want to know a little bit more
of whether if you do choose to move if
you truly can buy a house or if you
would be renting cuz I definitely don't
want you to think you you can afford to
move and buy another house if you truly
can't so do you have any other debt
okay um no we we really have tried to do
the um Dave Ramsey principles and um we
don't have any other debt um yeah we
have a house is worth 440,000 we have
140 left on it so we do have a a big
chunk to put down on another house um
just have to have to find a buyer in
this market okay and do you have an idea
of where you would go have you start
pricing out things are you just making a
lateral move or you trying to move up oh
you've been looking for houses for
months haven't
you yes weency offer yeah yeah but it
fell through
anyways she's like I don't want to talk
about that um yeah I don't yeah sorry so
as long as you you know obviously you
and your husband have to get on the same
page about this and you know the way we
teach I don't want you going into a
30-year mortgage I want you on a 15year
fixed is that what you were looking
at um we were GNA do the 30 and then
change when get better you would you
would no no come on Sarah do you know
why we suggest a 15 year
fixed right so so you can build wealth
and yeah I don't want you in debt for 30
years and 30 years you're going to be
I'm going to guess 60 you don't want to
be paying a mortgage that long I want
you out of debt so you can build wealth
so 15year fix for the payments no more
than 25% of your take-home pay and
family put a sign in the yard y'all are
spending months worrying about how long
it's going to take to sell the house you
could had a sign in the yard 60 days ago
you'd be halfway home put put the house
up for sale and see what happens and
then be ready to rock and roll